TO TEACH IS NUTRITION.
JUST SIMPLY DOES NOT FLY.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
AUTHOR OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, "FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS."
I CALLED THE GREAT ONE.
HE HOSTS "LIFE, LIBERTY, LIVE-I
LIVE-IN."
ALSO SYNDICATED RADIO HOST, THIS
SEND A HE HAS A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST, ME, FOR THE FULL HOUR.
GREAT ONE, THERE'S A LOT OF
SERIOUSNESS HERE.
WHEN WE GET TO THE HEART IS
THIS, THIS IS YOUR WHEELED WHEEL
THIS, THIS IS YOUR WHEELED WHEEO
THIS, THIS IS YOUR WHEELED WHEES
THIS, THIS IS YOUR WHEELED WHEEE
THIS, THIS IS YOUR WHEELED WHEE.
OUR FRAMERS AND FOUNDERS NEVER
IMAGINED THIS.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE IN COMMON
CLICKS MAKE A LOT OF THINGS BUT
THEY TALK ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
THEY COME FROM SANCTUARY CITIES
SANCTUARY CITIES THAT NULLIFY A
FEDERAL LAW AND THE SUPPORT
THAT.
THEY OBSTRUCT ICE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY REJECT THE IMMIGRATION LAWS
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
RULE OF LAW.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
THE CONSTITUTION IS THE LAW OF
THE LAND.
NOT THESE
THEY ARE NOT NANCY PELOSI.
IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S DUTY TO
UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION, NOT THE
ROGUE HOUSE WITH THE DEMOCRATS
IN CONTROL.
LITERALLY EVERY PRESIDENT WHO
CROSSES THE HOUSE REPRESENTED IT
WAS IN THE FUTURE UNDER THE
STANDARD LIST PROCEDURES THEY
HAVE IN PLACE WITH ABUSE OF
POWER AND OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS IS SUBJECT TO POTENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT IF THEY DO NOT BOW
TO THE WILL OF THE MAJORITY OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
FIRST OF ALL, OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS, THEY SAY, RIGHT?
HAS THE SENATE DONE ANYTHING
YET?
HOUSE THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE?
ITS OBSTRUCTION OF A ROGUE
FACTION OF RADICAL DEMOCRATS OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTED IN
SPIRIT WHEN THEY WON THE
MAJORITY, THEY RAN FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS NO OBLIGATION
TO THEM.
ABUSE OF POWER, THEY TALK ABOUT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES LIKE EVERY PAST
PRESIDENT EVEN SINCE
GEORGE WASHINGTON HAS FOUGHT TO
PROTECT THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENCY AGAINST A CONGRESS
THAT IS OUT OF CONTROL, THAT
DEMANDS THE INNERMOST
INFORMATION FROM HIS INNERMOST
WITNESS IS, INDIVIDUALS WHO
REPORT TO HIM.
HE GOES TO COURT AND THEY SAY
THAT'S OBSTRUCTION.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING: EVERY
PAST PRESIDENT WHO WILL BE
SUBJECT TO IMPEACHMENT UNDER THE
CURRENT ARTICLES BEING DEBATED
UNDER THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, JOHN ADAMS
WOULD BE IMPEACHED.
HE SHUT DOWN NEWSPAPERS AND
IMPRISONED REPORTERS BUT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
HE SHUT DOWN 300 NEWSPAPERS.
HE IMPRISONED REPORTERS.
THOMAS JEFFERSON WOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
THE LOUISIANA PURCHASE WITHOUT
BUDGET APPROVAL FROM THE
CONGRESS.
WOODROW WILSON WOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
HE RE-SEGREGATED THE CIVIL
SERVICE AND HE PUT POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AND REPORTERS IN
PRISON.
HE WOULD BE IMPEACHED.
THE GREAT FDR WOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
INTERNMENT OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS, ITALIAN-AMERICANS.
GERMAN-AMERICANS.
TOOK THE PROPERTY, TOOK THEIR
HOMES.
USE OF THE INTERNAL REVENUE
SERVICE AGAINST THE
"PHILADELPHIA INQUIRER" OWNER
AGAINST THE CONNECT
USE THE IRS AGAINST POLITICAL
OPPONENTS LIKE YOU BELONG.
FDR WOULD BE IMPEACHED 25 TIMES.
JOHN KENNEDY WOULD BE IMPEACHED,
USED IN THE IRS AND FBI AGAINST
HIS BILLABLE OPPONENTS, LEAKED
INFORMATION AGAINST THEM.
LYNDON JOHNSON WOULD BE
IMPEACHED, USED THE IRS, THE
FBI, AND THE CIA, TO PROTECT AND
TAP INTO HIS BELITTLE OPPONENTS
INTO CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS.
BY THE WAY, BECAME A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE WHILE HE WAS A
SENATOR.
WE HAVE A LOT OF IMPEACHMENT
GOING ON UNDER THESE BOGUS RULES
THAT THIS ROGUE HOUSE DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP HAS PUT IN PLACE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IT'S AN UGLY HISTORY WITH SOME
GAPS OF GOODNESS.
THE PARTY OF SLAVERY.
THE PARTY OF SEGREGATION.
THE PARTY OF JIM CROW.
AND WHEN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY DOES
WHAT IT DOES LIKE THAT, IT NEEDS
TO BE SLAMMED DOWN.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE SLAMMED DOWN
NOW!
THE NEXT DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES MUST BE
IMPEACHED.
NOT TO GET EVEN, NOT BECAUSE WE
ARE AT A LOW LEVEL.
BUT BECAUSE THE REPUBLICANS
CAN'T LIVE UNDER ONE
CONSTITUTION WHEN THE DEMOCRATS
LIVE UNDER AND OTHER
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING
TO STOP THEM.
ONE PARTY CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
ABUSE THE CONSTITUTION, WAITED
AROUND AROUND, WHILE THE OTHER
PARTY SINCE THERE AND TAKES IT.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY MUST BE
SLAPPED DOWN.
THE NEXT DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT,
IF THEY VOTE FOR IMPEACHMENT FOR
DONALD TRUMP, MUST BE IMPEACHED
AND WE HAVE THE BLUEPRINT.
IT'S THE PELOSI PROJECT.
SHE SAID IT TODAY, WE'VE BEEN AT
IT FOR 22 MONTHS, TWO YEARS.
WHAT YOU MEAN WE ARE BEING FAST
HERE?
WE HAVE THE PLAN.
ENDLESS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
SUBPOENAS.
NO RESORT TO JUDICIAL REVIEW.
NO DUE PROCESS.
ACCUSERS PROTECTED FROM SCRUTINY
PAIRED PHONE CALLS UPON LEADERS
MUST BE RELEASED.
THE PRESIDENT A POT OF CLOSEST
ADVISORS MUST TESTIFY.
TAX RETURNS.
BUSINESS RECORDS.
BUSINESS ASSOCIATES!
ALL SUBJECT TO CONGRESSIONAL
ACCESS AND DEMAND THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THAT'S THE PELOSI PROJECT.
IT MUST BECOME THE REPUBLICAN
PROJECT WHEN THERE IS A DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT.
ONE OTHER THING.
LOOK AT THIS DAMN THING.
THIS IS THE MUELLER REPORT.
IT TOOK THEM 9,000 PAGES TO SAY
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES IS AN INNOCENT MAN
WHO DID NOT COMMIT ANY CRIMES.
500 PACES, $40 MILLION.
THAT'S THAT.
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S 500 PAGES
LONG.
LOOK AT THIS.
WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
PORCH THAT SAYS, WHAT, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION -- ARE YOU
LISTENING, MR. HOLDER, SPIED ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN!
TAMPERING WITH EVIDENCE!
REPEATEDLY LIED TO THIS P26
REPORT TO GET BOGUS WARDS FOUR
TIMES RENEWED!
USED A DOSSIER PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THEY USE ALL OF THIS, LIES AND
CRIMES TO GET THIS!
A SPECIAL COUNSEL REPORT THAT
SAYS YOU ARE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS AN INNOCENT
MAN.
DONALD TRUMP IS UPHOLDING THE
CONSTITUTION.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE VICTIM!
IT'S THE MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, THE DEMOCRATS!
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO NEED TO BE
IMPEACHED!
THAT'S IT.